Hey, hey, welcome. My name is Cedric
Clyburn. I'm an open source engineer
here at Red Hat, and I think we can all
agree that context is the most important
aspect to building an AI application or
an agent, right? It's the reason that
harnesses have become so popular in
order to manage the LLM's context. But,
the thing is, no matter what model or
agent that you're using, there is so
much data that we're not able to use
properly because it's in unstructured
formats. I'm talking everything from
PDFs to presentations to contracts and
technical docs, even meeting notes,
scanned documents, diagrams, tables,
images, and more. And uh sorry, I know
that's a lot, but you understand what I
mean, right? All this data needs to be
transformed into something that an LLM
can actually understand. And that's why
by the end of this session, you'll
understand how to extract structure
between raw enterprise documents and use
it to power better downstream AI systems
like rag and agent. So, let's get
started. Now, I think Jensen from Nvidia
made this point super clear at his
keynote that unstructured data is
becoming this new context layer for AI.
And the reality though, for many teams,
and I know this personally working at
Red Hat, that PDFs and data are spread
across dozens of different systems. So,
we've got a lot to cover today. As you
might know, a large majority of the
world's data is unstructured, and so no
matter what model you're using, if
you're working with data like PDFs and
unstructured types of formats, this is a
bit tricky to work with. Because there
are solutions out there, but they might
be proprietary or require you to send
your private data to someone else's
server. And for not just text, how do we
take documents and their graphs or
tables and images to formats that LLMs
can understand like markdown or JSON?
And I'm going to show you how in the
session today because we're going to be
using an open source tool, part of the
Linux Foundation, that is called
Docling, and learn about extraction,
parsing, chunking, and much more. And
I've got some live demos for you, so
we're going to have some fun.
And just in case you'd like it, we have
the session slides here on the right and
a little overview of the specifics I'll
be showing you in today's session. But,
without further ado, let's get started.
So, why is there a need for advanced
document processing? As I briefly
mentioned before, you might have a lot
of technical documentation or meeting
minutes or different types of documents
and invoices that you need to use and
maybe rag or different type of
applications where the uh context is
provided to an LLM. So, whether it's rag
or retrieval augmented generation to
answer questions based on this data, or
you're using this to fine-tune a new
specialized model, well, data is this
key ingredient behind those
applications. And it doesn't matter if
you're using, you know, NVIDIA
acceleration or an open-source or
proprietary model, that data and the way
you process it is the key determining
factor in whether your answer is going
to be correct or incorrect for the user
or customer at the end of the day. And
that's what's most important.
And how important is it? Well, I have
this viral tweet from earlier where 20
scientific papers now feature a new
nonsensical term that doesn't exist
because AI misinterpreted a very old
article that was scanned and taken to a
PDF, merging two different words from
two different columns in this PDF. And
because researchers are using these
models in order to help them write, now
we have different types of scientific
papers that all feature this word and
are even being cited by other people.
And so, that's how important it is to
make sure that the data that we're
processing is processed in a way that's
accurate and not hallucinated and able
to be used confidently in our
applications that we're delivering to
users and customers. So, it's quite
important. Now, if we were to use a tool
like Docling that I can run on my own
machine, you could see that these two
words are quite far away from each other
and shouldn't have been combined in the
first place. But, that's how we're going
to learn about extracting this text here
in a second. Now, if we were to try a
simple PDF parser for a PDF like this
that includes um a table here, it has an
image, there's captions, and there's
regular sections of text, well, we might
get an answer like this here on the
right in markdown. You know, this might
be very fast and cheap to run even on
CPU, but the issue is is that a lot of
this text has been truncated, has been
merged, and isn't decipherable even by
me as a human. And if I sent this to a
model, I don't think I could trust that
the model could extract specifics from,
say for example, this table. Because the
table has been kind of just spit out
linearly, and this information isn't fit
for most use cases where I need to ask
questions or have an agent do validation
and extraction on this source data. So,
this isn't going to cut it, right?
There's undesired page headers, we don't
understand the table, and where's the
content from the image, right? It's not
even there.
When we're using frontier models, this
is um kind of not bad, right? But, it's
quite expensive. If I'm sending this to
a model that's maybe $30 per million
output tokens, you can see how this can
get quite expensive as I scale this up
to dozens or hundreds or, in a lot of
cases, thousands of PDFs that
organizations have to work through to
use an AI application. And the
difference is between maybe a 5.1 of a
model that was depreciated in the 5.2
version of a model make it tricky to
have structured output that's consistent
every single time. And so, while it
might be good quality and I can see that
most of this looks accurate in the
exported markdown, we might be
susceptible to hallucinations because
models are non-deterministic, and this
is really tricky at scale. And so, what
is the middle ground?
Well, that's where Docling comes in.
It's a fast and cheap, and most
importantly, local CLI and library that
I can use to take various types of input
sources and convert this to markdown,
JSON, and a Pydantic data type that I
can use in my applications and that I
can scale up if I have thousands of
different types of formats that need to
be used or translated to something like
markdown. And so we rendered this as
HTML, but you can see here we've got
this export of the specific table that
we had here previously. Because as a
PDF, this data type is spread out and
it's proprietary. So, it's hard to
extract this type of data from the
source PDF here. And I'll show you how
Docling does it by using a combination
of OCR and specific vision models that
extract the format and allow me to do
things like structure output if I only,
say for example, want a specific column
to be outputted from a content source.
So, it's really cool. And I've been
using it at Red Hat. My team uses it
because we have thousands of PDFs that
we need to work with, specifically from
product documentation. But also, we have
content like images that we want to
extract using vision models. And what
Docling does with a pip install Docling
is allow me to convert single documents
or websites or anything else to markdown
or whatever file type I want and be able
to work with the page layout so I don't
lose the consistency in the structure of
the source document. And there's a lot
of other integrations and for situations
where maybe you need to run this locally
or you don't want to pay for a service
or you have an air-gapped environment.
So, you're able to do this using this
open-source project that is part of the
Linux Foundation. So, before I show you
the quick demo that I want to highlight
the project, I want to talk a little bit
about scale and cost.
As I just mentioned it there earlier,
but there is a public use case I want to
show you from Leandro at Hugging Face
where he compared a source of common
crawl PDFs and where he did a little bit
of pre-work on them and actually
extracted the structure using OCR and
using DocLing in order to remove certain
parts and clean this up for the fine
PDFs export which is thousands of tokens
from PDFs around the web that you could
use for training a model etc. But the
two comparisons he did using GPU and
using CPU for DocLing allowed him to do
this at 50 times of a cost savings
compared to VLMs and OCR naively. And so
this is what's really cool is that you
can really scale this up and he did this
on CPU and not needing GPU which is
really cool. And it's not just document
conversion, right? This example was
getting things ready from PDFs, but
let's say we have images, right? This
image with vision language model was
able to be described and annotated,
right? From this specific image right
here, now we have all of this really
important context that can be used in a
rag application as an example, but also
just for the end user to be able to
understand what's happening in this
image. And say for example, the SME
doesn't work there anymore at the
organization, now we have a way to
understand what this is with the help of
an LLM whether proprietary or local. And
then finally, it's not just document
conversion and annotation, but also
structured output. Say for example, I
have this invoice and I need to extract
specifically the bill number, the total
invoice price, the name of the sender,
we're able to get that in a format
that is structured. So I don't have to
worry about, "Hey, it's going to pull in
like the headings and titles." No, I
just want the, you know, total invoice
price and the bill number and I can get
that in a format that's pydantic, but
also just super simple if I'm just
trying to get a a things out of a huge
document. So let's hop over to the demo.
Let me show you what I'm talking about.
And by the way, we're going to be using
this Docling workshop repository for the
demos today. So, feel free to check it
out. In this first example, we're going
to be using Docling to convert a popular
file type like a PDF because remember
that data is the foundation for all AI
systems. And in order to leverage that
data, we have to properly ingest
different file formats with accuracy.
And without doing that, we can lose
information or information can become
unreadable from tables and diagrams and
images. So, with Docling, what we're
able to do with a simple pip install
down here is start processing some of
these different file types. So, I'll
show you how we do that. First off,
we're going to be importing essential
components like the document converter
as well as some other dependencies. And
I'll show you the simplest way, which is
to just start out with a PDF that we
have online, which is Docling's own
research paper. And here you can see we
have different titles and subtitles. We
have components such as images and
captions that we have here. And at the
bottom of this PDF, we also have
something like a table here that we need
to extract as well as images that might
be helpful for our AI application or
agent. So, let me come back to the
notebook here and I'll show you how we
do this simple conversion by using the
Docling's document converter and
exporting this to markdown. So, here you
can see is a rough example of how fast
this can be for a eight-page PDF to be
able to export this in a way that an LLM
can start using, right? But at the same
time, this is a Pydantic data type. So,
you can see we can explore this PDF and
the number of pages and tables and see
what is on which page of this PDF and
export this into a variety of different
formats like markdown, HTML, dictionary,
and much more. But the real value here
is not just with basic text and columns,
but working with tables. So, this PDF
here has a variety of different tables
that we want to be able to extract. And
so, by doing a converter for this
specific document, we can then extract
these tables here and be able to export
this to a data frame so we can render
this out in our Jupiter notebook here.
So as I run this cell, you can see that
we've exported eight different tables
from that source PDF and we can list
these but also be able to get these in a
format ready to use in a rag application
or just to query with our LLM. So we've
taken a look at how to pull text and
tables from a PDF, but what about
visualizing and extracting images from
that source document as well? Now, for
this specific example, what we'll do is
set up a PDF pipeline that will allow us
to scale up the images and push this
into a document converter. So now when I
go to inspect the images and picture
content in the cells, we can see this
nicely mapped out where we have the
picture, so the source image, the
caption of that, and all of the embedded
text elements that we could use in some
type of retrieval augmented generation
application to ask questions about,
"Hey, what's happening in these
different photos in our source PDF?" I
think what would help here is also to be
able to visualize the document layout by
using the bounding boxes provided by the
layout visualizer here. So here what
we're going to do is visualize all of
the different elements and components
that can be extracted from, say for
example, that source PDF. So section
headers or text or subtitles or
different components such as that photo
that we just pulled and extracted from
the PDF. So this is one of the models
that Doc Lee provides which can be used
for situations where you might have
personal identifiable information from a
customer that you want to remove from a
source document type before you extract
that into your application. We can also
use vision language models in order to
enrich the source images and diagrams
that might be in these document types
using something like O llama or a
third-party LLM. So what we're going to
do here is set up a PDF pipeline that's
going to use a local running Granite
model and say, "Hey, give us a detailed
description of what's happening in this
image." And with that document
converter, we're going to go ahead and
display that enriched document by
calling the OpenAI endpoint with Ollama
that we have running locally at the
completions endpoint. And so here we
have an annotated caption of what's
happening with that DocQuery pipeline
image that we were taking a look at
earlier. Where originally we were just
pulling the caption, but now we can use
a vision language model to describe
what's happening in these photos. And
with all this additional information,
this can help us to build a really solid
RAG pipeline to where we can do
questioning and answering over our
source data. And for this example, I
want to show you what's known as
chunkless RAG or agentic RAG using
DocQuery. And now by starting off with
our document outline, so processing a
PDF with DocQuery like we just did, we
can allow an LLM to be able to pick the
most relevant part of the document that
is related to the user's question and
pull that full text from the DocQuery
document itself to try to answer that
question for the user. And this can run
in a agentic loop. And what's really
important here is that we're doing RAG
but without having to use a chunker or
embedding model or vector database,
etc., etc. So the index ends up being
the markdown outline of the document.
Now when the user asks a question, the
entire retrieval index typically would
be thousands of vectors in a database
where we would do semantic similarity to
make sure, "Hey, these sections are
similar to the user's question." But for
us, what we're going to do is be able to
see a markdown outline of the document
with each section summary outline. So if
the LLM is looking for something about
getting started with DocQuery, well it
can just pull from this reference of
text to say that DocQuery can be
installed from PyPI. And that's the
entire retrieval index. So let's say we
have a query, "What are the main AI
models used in DocQuery?" Well we're
setting up a rag agent here to be able
to iterate on that specific question
about five times. So, we see that there
are 20 sections available when the user
is asked the question, and we're going
to search for that specific part of text
that talks about the AI models and be
able to determine, "Hey, is this
relevant to answering the question?" And
you can see here the final answer in one
iteration was pulled from that source
material without having to go in the
vector database but instead search that
docling document structure for the
specific text. So, it's a quite
interesting way to be able to answer
users' questions through this chunklist
retrieval augmented generation pattern.
And while this first example might have
been simple, what we can do is also pull
the IBM 2025 annual report into the
context here, which has 418 sections, so
it's much larger, and ask the question
like, "Hey, what was Red Hat's revenue
growth in 2025, and how did
to an overall software segment?" And so,
here we're going to be iterating
multiple times to figure out, "Hey, is
this section relevant to the user's
question?" And if not, we need to pull
in more information. And so, that is how
chunkless rag can work in a situation
where you're using a tool like docling.
But what happens when we have hundreds
or hundreds of thousands of PDFs that we
want to have processed? Well, this is
where we can deploy docling as a REST
API service using something that's known
as docling serve. This allows us to
scale things up and to run this as a
microservice as a container or through
Kubernetes. So, when we set things up
here, we're going to do a pip install
docling serve, and we're going to be
able to serve this from a CLI with
docling serve on a specific port, or
once we have that server started, be
able to send things to that specific
endpoint with different types of options
and arguments like, "Hey, do we want
OCR? Do we want a specific back end? Or
do we want images annotated? And so,
that's how we can scale things up and
allow this API endpoint to be able to
handle hundreds or thousands of
different document types at a time. And
let's say, for example, that you're
trying to build an AI agent, you can
also use the Docling MCP server. So,
this allows us to automate things with
our AI agent and give it the
capabilities that Docling has through
that model context protocol and allow us
to standardize the communication
between, say, for example, Claude Coder
Continue in our developer CLI to the MCP
server, which can handle the document
processing for us without us having to
know all of those different arguments
and commands. So, it makes it quite
easy. And the example I show here is by
using one of the Claude models on my own
Mac itself and connecting this to my VS
Code instance. So, let's understand the
tools that are available. For the MCP
server, we have conversion tools,
generation tools, say, for example, if I
want to process a specific part of a
PDF, and manipulation tools. And this is
all provided to the LLM and the agent
that we're going to be using with the
MCP server. So, here I'm just checking
that my local MLX server to run an LLM
that's running, and it looks like we've
got Quinn 3.6 here. And we're going to
verify that the Docling MCP server is
also running, which would be done using
UVX here. And so, we'll do that in this
cell here to make sure that the MCP
server is available. Now, in Claude
Coder or Codex or another type of AI
application, we're going to install the
extension. So, for us, this means adding
an MCP server in the config.yaml.
And now, at this point, we can use a
model and an MCP server to do things
such as, "Hey, convert this document and
give me a summary." Or, create a
document with a section of action items
and pull in a list from another PDF and
export that as markdown. So, we can use
all of those Docling components through
the MCP server in order to agentically
process and parse these documents using
an AI agent like Cursor or Claude Code
or one of the many open-source options
that are out there. Now, let's head back
to the slides and wrap things up. So,
let's put it all together. With Docling,
we've seen that we can take a PDF into
format like Markdown or JSON with a
fully local operation from our own
machine without even needing a GPU. It's
fast, it's cheap, and most importantly,
it's open-source. So, I encourage you to
check it all out. Behind the scenes,
there's different pipelines that use a
combination of OCR and layout analysis
to structure everything together, put it
together as a Pydantic Docling document
that then you can use to export to
different types of formats, create data
sets, chunk that using the Hybrid
Chunkier, and do so much more. It
integrates with a lot of different rag
frameworks and agentic systems and
harnesses. So, feel free to try it out.
And I want to give a big thank you to
the AI engineering team for having me
on. This is something that I'm really
passionate about with processing
documents, but also doing this in an
open-source way because, you know, we're
here at Red Hat and we love open-source.
So, feel free to check out the slides,
connect with me on LinkedIn. I
appreciate the opportunity, enjoy the
conference, and keep up with the AI
engineering ecosystem. Things are
looking super bright right now for the
open-source world and for AI engineers
in general. So, see you next time and
thanks for watching.